[Music]
europe needs the next step
of integration of of working closer
together
[Music]
we haven't done a big reform of the eu
and in almost 20 years we need to change
the institutions
and this is what this conference is all
about to discuss those changes
so i'm quite excited to to get this
process going now
starting the debate with citizens in
particular citizens of
all kinds of backgrounds all gender all
age from all across the european union
everyone everyone should participate
there
is a possibility for each and every
citizen in the european union to bring
their ideas to discuss
the ideas of others so these proposals
will shape the agenda
of this conference if you want to make
proposals on how to
change agricultural policy or how
migration works in the european union or
how can we be better
at climate change mitigation everything
is allowed we as the european parliament
need to make sure to that the necessary
changes to laws
to the budget to the treaties where
where necessary
are are actually put forward and
implemented
the future is in your hands
[Applause]
[Music]